the man who briefly ran Donald Trump's
2016 presidential campaign could be even
in more trouble tonight Paul Manafort is
already awaiting trial on serious
criminal charges now he's being accused
of trying to influence potential
witnesses this happens as lawmakers
learn more about two of the biggest
topics in Washington these days chief
intelligence correspondent Catherine
Herridge has our report tonight
the FBI's espionage chief bill frees
staff with direct knowledge of the
Clinton email and Russia investigations
testified for the first time behind
closed doors for house investigators
how's it going in there
pre staffs former number two FBI agent
Peter struck was a central player in the
Clinton email probe and later removed
from the Russia case for anti-trump bias
based on testimony and documents one
republican said struck appeared to be
running the show not only the text
messages that we have but the emails
that have been produced to the Oversight
and Judiciary Committees and so while
technically that may have been a bill
priest at call I think it was more Peter
struck driven one Committee Democrats
said pre stabs testimony was
straightforward direct and he intervened
was the extramarital affair between
struck an FBI lawyer Lisa Paige was
known he was a supervisor and so I think
that he took the appropriate actions
once he found out about the nature of
the relationship Republicans want more
information from priests stamp about the
alleged confidential human source the
contacted Trump campaign aides priest a
freely traveled overseas and lawmakers
pressed him on a May 2016 trip to London
and whether it was connected to the
Russia probe that struck launched two
months later those would be confidential
pre staff along with his former boss FBI
director James Comey and others are the
subject of the long-awaited Inspector
General's report into the FBI's handling
of the Clinton emails with congressional
committees in a holding pattern waiting
for the report to drop any day on
Twitter the president questioned quote
what is taking so long on crooked
Hillary and slippery James Comey adding
quote hope report is not being changed
and made weaker in a separate
development the
counsel alleged that former Trump
campaign chairman Paul Manafort tried to
tamper with potential witnesses to shave
their testimony in the money laundering
and tax fraud prosecution in a statement
a spokesman said quote mr. Manafort is
innocent and nothing about this latest
allegation changes our defense we will
do our talking in court the special
counsel believes manna Ford violated
bail conditions Paul Manafort ought to
be jail most likely I think should face
serious criminal penalties for witness
tampering and within the last few
minutes six and a half hours of
closed-door testimony has completed one
lawmaker described bills
peace peace trap pardon me as extremely
cooperative adding that based on the
latest information so documents
testimony and other records it seems
clear to them now that FBI agent Peter
struck played a much greater role than
previously known in the Clinton email
and the Russian investigations and they
emphasized a greater role than what's
indicated in those text messages spread
catherine herridge live on Capitol Hill
tonight captain thank you